in this video we'll talk about the
Crohn's disease which is a inflammatory
bowel disease characterized by chronic
inflammation in any part of the
intestine unlike
ulcerative colitis Crohn's disease occur
in any part of the small intestine and
not restricted to the colon
clinical features of Crohn's disease
include diarrhea abdominal pain weight
loss reduced appetite mouth sores blood
in this stool and few others
the risk factors include smoking stress
NZ over usage age is a risk factor in
general for IBD risks generally the
white people are more at risk for IBD
than the other races family history is
important because there is a strong
genetic component of Crohn's Disease
and dietary fiber is another factor that
govern the risk of Crohn's Disease
so the gut microbiota is another
important factor which dictates the
pathology of Crohn's Disease generally
it has been found that the pharmacies
and the bacteria dates are actually
reduced in number in case of Crohn's
Disease whereas the enterobacterial
number has increased dramatically
other than that adherent invasive E coli
and other kind of pathogenic bacterias
increases in case of Crohn's Disease
so the overall pathology is due to a
tilt in the balance of inflammation
generally the pro-inflammatory cytokines
and anti-inflammatory cytokines are
balanced in the intestinal situation and
this balance is modulated by cell types
like regulatory T cells th1 and th17 in
case of Crohn's Disease th17 th1 these
kind of pro-inflammatory T cell subtypes
increases in number whereas t-regulatory
cell decreases so overall there is an
excess of pro-inflammatory cytokine and
reduction in anti-inflammatory cytokine
that leads to the problem
so
it has been shown that the expression of
stat 3
interleukin-17 also increases in Colon
tissues th17 is one of the key regulator
and modulator in this particular disease
pathology il-17 is a pro-inflammatory
cytokine which is thought to be
important for Crohn's disease pathology
other than that antigen presenting cells
and other immune cells infiltrate the
overall intestinal tissues when there is
a bacterial invasion there is
inflammation in the local intestinal
lumen and the bacteria can get in but
detected by several antigen presenting
cells present in the intestine now these
antigen presenting cells would
eventually secrete inflammatory cytokine
and that would modulate the
differentiation of th0 type T cells into
th1 th2 or th17 subtype all of these
subtypes have their individual cytokines
that they secrete and all of these
cytokine actually helps to increase the
inflammation so overall we understand
that inflammatory increase is one of the
key factors involved in the Crohn's
disease Crohn's disease is not an
autoimmune disease it's an immune
Associated disease
now th cell can be differentiated into
several lineages th1 th2 then there is
th17
anti-follicular and many others actually
but in case of Crohn's Disease Recent
research has shown th17 to be very
important anyway th17 T cells are
pro-inflammatory and they play important
role in antifungal immunity
th17 cells are dominant dominant influ
infiltratory cells in case of Crohn's
Disease and the secret cytokines like
interleukin-22 interleukin 21 and
interleukin-17 which all lead to massive
inflammation of the intestine and that
has effect on lungs and the overall gut
health
so let's talk about some histological
features so if we cut a cross section of
the intestine we can see the tissues
like this mucosa submucosa and
muscularis now in case of Crohn's
disease where inflammation has increased
one can see increased amount of immune
cells clumped together and forming a
granuloma here you can see in the
histological image there is a granuloma
formation and this is basically many
dead immune cells along with the
pathogen along with the pathogenic
bacterium together
now when it comes to genetics two
important risk factors are associated
one is a mutation and polymorphism in
the gene which encodes for pattern
recognition receptor nod to and the
overall components of the nuclear NF
Kappa beta signaling pathway so uh kind
of like defect in any of these aspects
can lead to or can increase the risk of
the Crohn's disease
now Crohn's disease overall symptom can
also be extra intestinal so there are
many extra intestinal in manifestations
in this disease like there are problems
with hepatobiliary system there could be
sherosis there could be colorectal
cancer small bowel cancers there could
be respiratory complications like
obstructive sleep apnea chest infection
there could be problem in vascular
system leading to portal hypertension
then embolism is another problem there
could be bone related issues in this
disease but these are all secondary and
doesn't occur in all the patients so the
overall disease is quite variable
let's talk about some diagnosis so
endoscopic Imaging is one of the gold
standard but anyway from the biopsy
sample if histological analysis is done
then granuloma formation could be
strikingly visible in these Crohn's
disease patients and now there are
different laboratory biomarkers presence
of specific CD active protein which
generally increases with inflammation
which is an indirect readout anyway so
okay
so there are other proteins like
calprotectin if those proteins are
highly found in the fecal extracts then
it could be indicator of Crohn's Disease
but none of these biomarkers are very
specific to this particular disease
novel biomarkers are required to
understand this disease and diagnose
this disease in a non-invasive fashion
question is when to see a doctor so if
you see persistent change in your bowel
habits and you have
pain in the stomach or let's say when
you whenever you eat you feel some kind
of like inflammatory sensation then it's
time to visit the doctor but what are
the treatment options generally these
particular disease is treated with some
amount of antibiotics because the
bacterias are the key starting point for
inflammation
now once it cannot be controlled with
antibiotics then it can be then it can
the immune response can be suppressed by
steroids and thiopurine later on more
specifically anti-tnf or cytokine
therapy can also be done
to reduce the overall inflammatory
manifestations and the ultimate thing is
to remove those portion which is highly
inflamed using surgery but surgery
doesn't cure the disease because many
portions of the gut can be or in the
intestine can be affected in case of
Crohn's disease so which part should be
removed other part can also be other
parts are equally susceptible for this
disease manifestation
so this disease doesn't have an absolute
treatment but it can be managed at
several different levels so I hope this
was useful get notes and flashcards in
Facebook page and Instagram page you can
support our Channel using super thanks
you can pay via paytm PayPal or UPI see
you in next video